hello my name is michael johnson i'm the
ceo and one of the co-founders of
visicall today i'll be talking about
identifying the ideal and vitro liver
model for various research applications
and how we can apply different liver
models to answer different types of
research questions
now the overview of this presentation
starts off with some background on
visicol who is the company where do we
come from what we do i'm going to dive
into an overview of various liver and
vitro models what they're used for why
they're important where the field is
currently and i'm going to dive into
three different examples 2d liver cell
culture models focusing on the hirel
micro liver platform i'll discuss 3d
liver cell culture models with a strong
focus on nash and drug-induced liver
injury and then lastly i'll touch upon
tissue slice x-zivo model so actually
using slices from real and vivo tissues
as an in vitro model
now to kick it off with some background
on visical visicol is a company that i
founded as a spinout from rutgers
university about six years ago and we
are an industry leader in advanced
models and tissue imaging focused on
improving accelerating drug discovery
and development through contract
research services so we operate
primarily as a contract research
services provider but also sell a few
reagents kits and also liver cell
culture models through the hirel
platform
we have a worldwide customer base all 20
of the top 20 pharmaceutical companies
in the world are clients we also of
course work with medium and small sized
pharma companies as well as other
prestigious research institutions and
non-governmental organizations we have
an expertise in drug discovery assay
design oncology immunology inflammation
and of course liver disease and liver
disease modeling
the two focus areas for us where we play
as far as services are advanced imaging
and advanced cell culture when we
started our company originally about six
years ago the focus was squarely on
advanced tissue imaging but after a
short while we had a lot of researchers
coming to us to image 3d cell culture
models organoids and steroids in 3d
using unique confocal and light sheet
technologies that we had developed and
from there we decided to build our own
advanced cell culture capabilities and
end-to-end assays involving advanced
cell culture models and of course in
that space the high focus area initially
was liver and now we've expanded as an
industry to lots of other models which
i'll not touch upon today but of course
there's lots of other 3d cell culture
models that are out there that are now
widely used in academic as well as
industrial settings but for us we do 2d
and 3d cell culture models and assays as
well as x vivo tissue slice assays with
a strong focus on high content imaging
endpoints and we do a lot of work on
custom model development if we don't
have a model or we don't have a model
for a third party that meets the needs
of our researchers
we were acquired back in may of 2021 so
after being a stand-alone company for a
little over five years we sold visical
to bico bico is a swedish-based life
sciences company that is a family of 15
different companies that are broadly
focused on this concept of bio
convergence essentially we operate as a
tool
reagent consumable equipment company
that's trying to facilitate life
sciences research with a strong focus on
cell culture robotics automation
dispensing other technologies which help
researchers accelerate their drug
discovery and development processes as
well as basic and translational research
and for us as a company what we're doing
around this bio convergence concept is
we're taking a bunch of different
technologies and combining them together
to accelerate the time it takes to get a
drug from the lab all the way to a
patient so for us we're very focused on
advanced cell culture assays and models
which i'll talk about today advanced
imaging tools and then also ai and image
analysis so we generate huge amounts of
data as a company through our high
content imaging and through our 3d cell
culture assays and 2d cell culture
screening and we use advanced tools for
data processing to turn that into
something useful that allows us to make
more informed decisions as part of the
drug discovery and development process
now for liver cell culture when we think
about liver cell culture models and
assays there's a lot of unmet needs that
we're working towards addressing liver
toxicity
is one of the most common sources of
late-stage clinical failure for
therapeutics and necessitates more
clinically relevant in vitro models we
need to bridge the gap if we're able to
better predict toxicity in inexpensive
and high throughput in vitro assays
we're better able to avoid late stage
clinical failures that result in a
longer time to get their future to
market and of course also higher prices
for therapeutics for patients which we
want to avoid so we're trying to shorten
that time by better predicting what's
going to fail
liver disease so nash afld and hbv are
of the most common diseases out there in
the developed world and affect tens of
millions of people
in the u.s alone and trying to develop
in vitro models that mimic these help us
better understand these diseases and
also develop therapeutics for these
unmet needs
where we operate as a company is we have
several different liver cell culture
models which i'll dive into today that
have different advantages and
disadvantages depending upon the
research context you're working in
now as i touched upon in the last slide
we look at drug induced liver injury and
late stage clinical failures
a lot of this is caused by toxicity and
apatotoxicity is the number one toxicity
that we're seeing in the late stage
that's causing these failures
and of course by you know reducing that
in late stage we're able to improve this
funnel of developing new drugs and
reduce the overall time and the cost to
do it
there's several toxicities which are
leading causes as well but liver
toxicity definitely takes the cake and
also disease modeling for nash and other
disease ideologies that i mentioned
the focus of this presentation though is
on which model is right for your
research question there's a lot of
researchers that are looking at organs
on a chip and bodies on a chip and these
very complicated models and we see these
papers come out about
the end of animal studies and of course
we're trying to reduce animal studies
we're trying to reduce human studies
and get drugs to market more quickly but
when we look at in vitro systems there's
never going to be a model that answers
all of our research questions or earlier
in drug discovery
we want higher throughput and lower cost
when we're later in the process we want
higher relevancy
the price is gonna be higher the
throughput's gonna be lower so there's
always a balance between throughput
price and relevancy depending upon where
you are in part of the drug discovery
process and i'll touch upon several
models today but we look at 2d and 3d
and xevo
they have different characteristics some
are really relevant as far as mimicking
the micro environment within the body
while others are much less relevant but
much higher throughput so a lot of where
you're picking a model and what model
you pick is based upon which of these
characteristics you need but no model is
going to meet all three of these
parameters at the same time
we as a company at visicall
we have a broad spectrum of liver models
because again we recognize that no model
meets every need so at our company we
have a broad range of tata talks the mpk
models as well as looking at
mitochondrial metabolic immune cell
infiltration and efficacy within liver
models and also modeling liver diseases
like nfld and nash and we have this
spectrum which i'm showing from
less complicated to more complicated on
the far right with our 2d cell culture
model system being the sherelle
microliver model system
this system is primary hepatocytes it's
ten different species and we actually
recently acquired this platform back in
september of 2021 and integrated it into
visical and this has allowed us to
develop the most broad liver portfolio
in vitro models in the marketplace
stretching from 2d all the way to x vivo
models which i'll touch upon in a moment
we the company also have simple steroids
so spheroids allow us to have the
complex three-dimensional structure that
we see within the body in a format with
a little more complexity than 2d it
allows us to answer different questions
than we could in 2d
we also have complex steroids as a
company so multiple cell types combined
into a simple model as well as ipsc
derived models and then lastly
external tissue slice models are when we
take a tissue an actual liver in this
case we slice it into about 200 micron
thick sections
we put them on trans wells and we keep
them in culture for a period of time we
can do that with healthy tissues we're
inducing nash we can do with healthy
tissues we also do with nash tissues for
example and actually look at the
amelioration of disease in actual human
tissue but in a vitro format so we're
taking one tissue and turning into lots
of different
experiments through the ex xvivo
platform which i'll talk more on later
but again these models are going from
less complex to more complex in the far
right
the trade-offs are throughput and cost
which i'll touch more upon later so not
every model is great for every research
question i'm going to dive into a few of
these examples in more detail and also
touch upon which one might be right for
your specific research question
the first one i'll dive into is 2d liver
cell culture this is the one that we're
most familiar with as of 5 6 seven years
ago most folks were doing 2d cell
culture work or just um suspension work
and as we've shown that models become
able to answer questions better than 2d
and suspension work we started shift
over to 3d and other more complicated
models but for a long long time those
were our primary models that we use 2d
and suspension especially in the
patasite space and the model that we've
integrated into our services and we've
acquired recently
is a hirel micro liver model so unlike a
lot of other 2d cell culture platforms
that are out there this unique system
allows us to have long-term metabolic
stability compared to just plating
hepatocytes on a simple plate like most
researchers have done this platform has
10 different species so we're able to
look at not just primary human parasites
but also dog and cat and mouse and
rabbit and a few others as well
it's been published in over 100
publications to date it's compatible
with standard automation analytical
equipment and it's used by most major
pharmaceutical companies for dmpk work
as of today
so it's a very unique platform really
unique technology and the rationale
behind it is that we were as a company
as a call looking for a really strong
metabolically and finitely stable model
and hurrell is able to have metabolic
and phenotypic stability for over four
weeks in culture and sometimes much
longer than that and also able to
sustain infectious diseases like hpv
which makes it a really unique 2d cell
culture platform
the format for cherelle micro livers is
just standard 24 48 96 well plates and
we're able to put
several different species on a singular
plate and sell it as a product if
researchers actually want that but again
the strong thing here is for any of
these species that we're working with
with the unique purell cell culture
approach we're able to get over four
weeks ability and metabolic activity
which again we just don't see in
traditional suspension or
traditional 2d cell culture which allows
us to to look at low clearance compounds
in a really substantial way compared to
other models that are out there
i mentioned the phenotypic stability we
have published several papers on this
but um as far as comparing to other
models it's just not even close
phenotypic stability of this realm
system is the gold standard in the space
as far as long-term long-lasting
stability especially compared to 3d cell
culture models that are out there
and for metabolic competency it has the
highest sensitivity and predictive
capability in the space compared to the
other 2d compared to 3d and a lot of
that is due to just a large number of
parasites in the system that also is why
it's so helpful with looking at low
clearance compounds this urel microliver
model platform is really ideal for
metabolism studies pka pd studies
and really just a tried and true
approach for looking at those we as a
company didn't have a model that filled
the space which is why the acquisition
of sorel fit in so nicely to what we're
doing it's a model that meets this use
case incredibly well um it also provides
us a lot of flexibility with species so
if we have a result or we have a unique
finding with rabbit for example or with
monkey for example we can go into the
urel system and on a single plate
compare multiple different um
hepatocytes species of sites with each
other and see if that was species
specific or if we see that in multiple
species and we can look at the
underlying metabolism and metabolites as
well and see exactly what's going on so
really a great great model for
metabolism
the next one i'll dive into is 3d cell
culture now 3d cell culture has evolved
dramatically five six years ago we were
at conferences society of toxicology and
slas this was primarily a lot of
academic researchers and then really
rapidly every pharma company every
biotech company started to rapidly adopt
3d cell culture initially as steroids
and then as organoids and now looking at
much more complicated systems but the
rationale is that for a lot of research
questions 3d better mimics what's
happening with the body it better
answers our research questions and
allows us to answer unique questions
that we couldn't otherwise address for
example if you're trying to understand
how a large molecule drug penetrates
into
a tumor for example of course out of
this context the 3d cell culture
environment allows us to look at spatial
context allows us to look at
infiltration penetration um and also
cell specific things like if we have a t
cell assay where are those t cells going
are we getting t cell killing where is
it is on the outside the inside so we're
able to answer more complex questions
and add a spatial context to the biology
into the research our body is of course
in 3d it's not in 2d it's not growing on
a plastic plate and therefore having a
3d cell culture model starts to better
mimic the body and allow us to answer
more complex questions
one of the models that we use regularly
at visicol is a primary human apatocite
steroid model so very simple just
primary human parasites in a model it's
affordable for dialyzed screening it's
in a corning ula plate so we're able to
have it compatible with high throughput
screening if we want to have imaging as
our readout and typically these are
about 200 to 300 microns in diameter
going much beyond that the problem you
start to have is of course the inside
starts to become necrotic imaging
becomes a little more challenging as
light penetration refractive index
mismatches prevents you from imaging the
entire structure so we stick to about
200 300 microns in diameter for these
models
but typically do it in 96 or a 384 well
plate format
and we look at large screens of
compounds what we're able to show is
compared to 2d
models we do have a higher sensitivity
of course this isn't a dialyze assay so
looking at drug-induced liver injury but
um compared to 2d model layer we get a
better ability to look at false
negatives false positives and overall
just a much more sensitive assay in in
this circumstance compared to
traditional 2d so again not great for
all research questions when we look at
something like metabolism we're not able
to look at flow clearance compounds
we're not able to have the same type of
sensitivity in that respect that we do
see here for dily so there's a really
unique model for dye lime and it's also
in a high throughput format which makes
it really ideal for screening large
numbers of compounds when i say large i
mean several hundred
compounds at a single time
and the next model i'll talk about is
just um a simple model so fg2 uh
steroids so um cancer cell line here
we're looking at a carcinoma and we're
able to look at something very simple so
looking at steatosis so we can use the
same simple 3d cell culture model
instead of looking at primary
hepatocytes this time we're looking at
hepg2 it allows us to look at something
as simple as lipid accumulation over
time
the reason i show this is because what
we're showing here is lots of different
models for lots of different research
questions hepg2 is different from
primary parasites in a bunch of respects
and one of the main respects is that
it's you have to do is a cell line so we
can use continually the same sort of
model the same kind of thing we see with
hep rg whereas we work with primary
hepatocytes they vary back to batch they
vary donor to donor if we pool donors we
don't know exactly what we're getting
unless we do really thorough
characterization so if we need a high
level of reproducibility we don't need
that much complexity we don't need
primary hepatocytes perhaps something
like hepc2 or heparg becomes a little
bit more appropriate so again there's
other factors involved but not every
model is perfect for every application
then diving into the next one we call
this model open liver hep rgnp and what
this is is it's hepa rg's with
non-principal cells so we have several
different cell types in a steroid model
in this model we're able to look at
because we have those npcs indirect
immune mediated dily um so again if this
is a question we're going after we need
a slightly more complicated model than
just actually two cells or just half rg
cells in a steroid so we're basically
the model on the research question
instead of the other way around we're
not trying to force a model into a
research question
and then um a model a model like that
can be used for other research questions
as well like looking
at nash
nash and non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease are things that we don't hear a
lot about but these affect a large
proportion of the population worldwide
we look at non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease this is essentially due to poor
diet poor diet is of course ubiquitous
in the developed world and the
prevalence of this is incredibly high
so when we're talking about
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease we're
talking about the accumulation of lipids
in the liver inflammation fibrosis and
eventually in advanced stages of this
disease the liver starts to shut down
and not perform how it's supposed to
so very serious disease the disease
process takes an incredibly long period
of time this is a decadal long disease
process so of course modeling it in a
vitro setting in a few weeks is
challenging but as a company we're
trying to develop models that help
researchers better understand this
long-term process can we slow this
disease progression down can we reverse
it what can we do to actually improve
this process here so a model that we've
developed for this which i alluded to
before is this hepa rg and mpc model it
contains hepatocytes in the form of hepa
rg cells uh we have our liver sinusoidal
endothelial cells we have cup for cells
affiliate cells calamity sites so most
of the major players you see in the
liver are represented in this model and
that allows us to mimic the disease
state of nash in this spheroid context
in the same size that 200 micron
diameter steroid and with this model
we're able to show um glycogen storage
transporter protein expression p450
enzyme expression and with nash we have
several assays that we've developed but
just looking at high content imaging
data here we're able to look at things
like collagen deposition
alpha sma of course live dead
pgfr beta and understand how
different compounds might ameliorate
this cascade how they might slow down
collagen deposition
and it's a really strong asset we've run
a lot for uh for researchers in the
space we also of course do qpcr and
eliza's and other readouts as well but
the images tell a great story here we
look at them so this is an asset
amenable to a lot of different
endpoints but as a company we do a lot
of imaging so you tend to see a lot of
imaging data coming out of our lab as a
big focus of a lot of our assays so
again we're tailor fitting the model
based upon the research question for
this question we need our npcs we can't
just do with rgs so we're using a
slightly more complicated slightly more
expensive model to answer this research
question than we would for some other
research questions
and then yeah looking at the next one
again so same frg npc model and we're
able to show here which is two compounds
that folks are looking at today el
fibronor and pioblidizone um what
happens uh with different concentrations
over time as far as looking at collagen
deposition and alpha sma and we're able
to show is again again this model is
very reproducible works very well with a
pretty big assay window with our
controls and are able to
evaluate compounds in a very meaningful
and accurate way for our clients
um and then the next one here is a pan
collagen and alpha smooth muscle active
analysis again looking at these same
compounds for alphanor and pyolitizone
fibrosis was induced in these
and we're able to look at that we're
able to quantify it and the assay window
again is pretty large for this asset
which makes it quite powerful for the
researchers that are looking at
different compounds and their effect on
of course college of deposition and just
generally the the nash cascade
um the next one um actually we'll look
into the next model type are precision
cut tissue slices in this case pcls and
cut liver slices precision cut liver
slices are an alternative to their own
sort of type of in vitro model for
evaluating anti-fibrotic agents as well
as other research questions we as a
company have three different approaches
we have normal human tissue we have
disease human tissue and we also have
mouse disease tissue in our normal human
tissue we can induce nash or we can just
use them as normal human tissue we've
also done some work with hpv human
tissue as well the idea behind this
model
is that we take just tissue shortly
after a patient is deceased um or
shortly after an animal has been sacked
and we take um the tissue in this case
liver we section it using a compressed
tone from a company called precisionary
into about 200 micron thick hockey pucks
we put those on transwells and we're
able to keep those in culture for
anywhere between two and five days
depending upon the type of tissue that
we're getting some tissue is of course
healthier than others and rodents are
different than humans of course
um but for these types of assays usually
we're looking at about 400 slices we're
looking at multiple time points
we're doing eliza's we're doing qpcr we
can also do high content imaging and
histology as well as readouts we tend to
do a lot of readouts from these assays
just because getting a human liver is
quite expensive we want to make sure we
get out as much as possible
but this is a really unique assay
because we're taking the native tissue
architecture we're taking the native
tissue itself and using it as individual
models you're working with real human
tissue and keeping a culture the problem
of course the downside of this model
especially in regards to nash is that
we're trying to recapitulate a disease
process which takes 20 30 40 years in a
model in a few days so of course the
findings that we have are not going to
be one to one the concentrations are not
going to be
similar but what we're seeing is that it
gives us a really good model of what's
happening with the real disease the real
pathways that we're looking at within
the body
so again it's a model so not perfect but
we've seen great success with this so
far with our clients and i've run dozens
of studies so far with this pcls format
look at the the mouse study we usually
use a mouse ccl4 model so we're
acquiring the tissue we're generating
the slices and we're keeping it in
culture and the ccl4 model is from a
partner company of ours called nellier
discovery in pennsylvania we don't have
pre-co uh pre-culture uh we treat for 72
hours with an alk-5 inhibitor
and then what we're looking at here is
um the top right pdgfr beta and alpha
sma with and with dappy and blue here
and we're able to look at the untreated
versus treated and see how
alpha sma area increases we can quantify
it by a bunch of different ways but with
high content data we're looking at in
this case area we can look at volume for
column deposition or total column
deposition and also in parallel we're
looking at qpcr and other readouts as
well we're able to show that it's again
a very powerful assay with a really
strong assay window for looking at
compounds that hopefully are going to
ameliorate nash
or reverse the disease process
for the normal human pcls we can
stimulate the disease state so we're
looking at f-zero and f1 human livers
pre-culturing for five hours and then
stimulate it for 48 hours
and then typically we're doing a free
fatty acid simulation for inducing
collagen deposition and then we're
quantifying again with the same
histology high content or qpcr slash
elisa
readouts from this assay the benefit of
this of course is human so it's more
more relevant than looking at a rodent
model but the disadvantage is of course
we're beholden to when we can actually
get tissues and the tissues don't always
meet our requirements we have to have a
very specific set of requirements for
our assays but of course we don't always
know all the information about our
patients
so it's a little bit challenging to
actually identify that the model meets
our specific needs but we've
demonstrated a strong ability to get
livers at least several per month of
human healthy livers for these studies
but in this case we're inducing disease
states that's another disadvantage in
the context of nash
compared to actually getting a nash
tissue itself
now we can get nash livers which is what
i'm showing here and of course visibly a
nash liver looks very different than a
human healthy liver the problem with
nash livers is they're harder to get and
one of the reasons for that is we don't
always know the true medical history of
a person it's hard to get a person who
has nash but has never had an alcohol
drink in their life so trying to balance
the two is always an issue and these
come less frequently of course than
healthy human livers um so it's a
powerful assay in that we're not only
getting the human tissue we're getting
the human tissue with the disease state
we're trying to treat and when we're
trying to look at ameliorate the disease
state in the tissue itself so a couple
advantages disadvantage of course is the
tissue availability
and meeting the specific criteria that
we have there's also disease state
variability so some nash livers are very
different from other natural hybrids we
can have patient data that tells us that
a patient's really healthy and we get
the liver out it doesn't look that bad
in other cases it's a complete surprise
so we don't always know exactly what
we're going to get there's a lot of
variability from donor to donor for
these studies
but the question remains what model is
right for you when we're developing a
research project we work really closely
with our clients we usually have several
constitutive calls at the beginning of
the process to discuss the project and
what we're trying to find out with all
of our clients is what is truly required
we see it as our duty to balance cost
throughput and relevancy we could give a
client a really expensive model um that
answers the research question but if
it's not needed we want to avoid it so
instead of using a rg mpc model perhaps
we're using a hepg2 model or perhaps
we're using just primary hepatocytes so
we're always trying to balance what's
actually required to answer a research
question because we can always make
something more complicated we can put an
organ on chip we can add microfluidics
we can add all these things but if they
don't actually help us better answer our
research question and they're
challenging to validate and they have
other problems why are we using that
model so for us when we're looking at a
model and any researchers looking at a
model
first question we always ask is where
are you at during the discovery process
and how many compounds do you have if
you have lots and lots and lots of
compounds you want high throughput you
probably want lower cost per n
and while relevancy is important you
always want to have as much relevancy as
possible perhaps you don't need an
extremely relevant model and you can get
by with a more simplistic system perhaps
a 2d cell culture model of just one
singular cell type instead of a 3d model
or a tissue slice model
the next question is which model can
mimic the disease state you're looking
for so there's lots of models 2d and 3d
which will just not mimic your disease
state we can't get nash if we don't have
mpcs
so of course we have to have mpcs in a
more complicated model and there's
several 3d cell culture models that will
not
become infected or not hold infection
for a long period of time and stay
viable so the ability to actually infect
a model if you're looking at hpv for
example is super important so we want to
see what is the research question can
the model actually address it and then
lastly
is there sufficient validation data to
support your research question do we
have an assay window in the model if we
run it for your intended purpose do we
have a lot of control data which
compares the model and vitro to vivo
where we can say that yes these results
will be indicative of what happens in
vivo because at the end of the day the
whole point of these models these more
complicated models is that we want to
better bridge the gap between in vitro
and vivo and if we're not doing that we
shouldn't be using that model we should
be using something that's more
traditional more standard and has a lot
more data behind it so these are kind of
the key questions to ask there's of
course a lot of other questions as well
but what i really want to paint is that
no singular and vitro model is going to
answer all of your research questions
and in vitro models are not going away
they're not going to be replaced um with
some organized chip or body on chip at
least for a really long period of time
and even then they will always have a
place so individual models are great as
is any model but at the end of the day
they are just a model and you have to
choose the one that meets the most
makes the most sense for your research
question cost throughput and relevancy
and with that i i thank you for your
time if you do want to discuss your
inventory program if you want to dive
into models in more detail learn more
about the assays we have here at visicon
talk about the hirel models please reach
out to me directly my email is
michael.johnsonvisitcall.com or reach
out to us at uh infophysical.com and we
can connect you with somebody from our
in vitro team to discuss further so i
appreciate the time and again if you
have any questions please reach out